The german-made Leopard 2 tank is used
by more than a dozen European countries
and by Canada but Berlin needs to give
approval before any other armies can
export their leopards to Ukraine
Poland's prime minister says he has now
formally requested approval
mateosky says Poland and other nations
are already training Ukrainian soldiers
to use the tanks is
he accused Berlin of delaying and
dodging on the decision German
Chancellor Olaf Schultz will ultimately
make the call his reluctance likely
influenced by Germany's history the last
time that German tanks were rolling
across this land was during World War II
and you know some German leaders have
said that they they don't want there to
be the Optics of a once again a German
tank rolling across Ukraine NATO Chief
yens stoltenberg appeared to apply apply
pressure on a visit to Berlin battle
tanks are of course important both to be
able to repel Russian and new offensives
but also for Ukraine to be able to
retake territory later on Monday news
reports indicated Germany will now
export leopard twos and will also
approve others to do the same Canada has
112 of the tanks prime minister Justin
Trudeau was asked about them on Monday
we have nothing to announce today but
we'll continue to look at how best
Canada can help U.S media meanwhile
report that Washington will send some of
its Abrams Tanks to sending those to
Ukraine is going to be a lot more
difficult to do than sending leopard
tanks it could take months to fully
deploy the complex Abrams Tanks any
official announcements will likely
provoke a strong response from the
Kremlin Russia's foreign minister said
Monday that the west and Russia have now
moved Beyond a hybrid War to almost a
real War Redmond Shannon double news
London